the guys here were like hey Ronnie
missing a show on Wednesday when the
wedding was until Saturday right they
think you're checked out already because
you know you're retiring
I'm checked out that's why I have made
these arrangements a long time ago I
wasn't really picking on Ronnie I just
felt like yeah nobody here misses show
days like unless it's an absolute
emergency I mean I think Fred left the
show one time when his daughter was born
that might have been the only feminist
one day I arranged it have the day
covered for me the day covered for you
is just driving no it's everything no it
isn't they can't come in here and be you
your attitude saying something I was on
party leave why can you wait until after
the show on Wednesday to go this wedding
why can't you [ __ ] mind you didn't
question why did you keep it a secret
that you were officiating no I didn't
want to ruin the guy's wedding I didn't
want to have to bring it up on the air
hey the other thing I heard was you
wanted shulie to help you with your
speech your wedding speech and he blew
me off
yeah I heard okay fine so I went out and
did on my own
Oh Ronnie you also after you everything
on my own that's all that there's no
reason for you have to come in here and
say anything well but no you didn't I
asked you weeks ago and you said to me
we're gonna help me okay did I pressure
you no I never said it nothing never
even follow up with me on it exactly I
never said a word he never told me who
these people were
I don't have to tell you that people why
did you want to go write a [ __ ] thing
if you would've came to me I would have
told you [ __ ] about these people oh so I
haven't did why would I could tell you
[ __ ] so you could go around spreading
[ __ ] [ __ ]
a bunch of bullcrap what did I spread
what are you talking all I heard was
[ __ ] [ __ ] bullcrap there was a lot
anything yeah it's good if you shake you
know anything cuz I wasn't gonna tell
you [ __ ] till you said that want me to
write all that so you does I know you
you're a [ __ ] you're [ __ ] you know
i'ma walk your information give it to
everybody
Why ask somebody you don't trust in the
first place to do this that's the
question yeah Ronnie why you ask a guy
you can't even tell anything to that's
why I'm so confused about this I don't
get
me I I thought maybe for once you could
put something aside and help me out with
something I did I put an assignment of
unit but you know I see that can't work
but how am I supposed to do with what
you gave me you said can you help me
come up with some stuff for this wedding
I'm marrying these people I said okay
sure and that's the last I heard about
it what am I supposed to show up with
five pages no what should he have done
all the editors say hey listen give me a
call on this day we'll sit down and
we'll do it now it's my job now it's
mine
the delivery of your favor if you're
worried about a bunch you have my wife
and kids you got [ __ ] on the road yeah
that's fine
you asked them and then you weren't
gonna beg them again yes you were it's
about going hey man remember we talked
about this last week buddy feels funny
doing that anything oh no what makes
somebody feel funny like how many
[ __ ] rules is this guy have I had no
rules do it did you get any laughs
during the wedding yeah yeah did you
laughs cries yeah Oh tears yeah no
kidding yeah that's right tugged on the
emotional heartstrings yeah were they
laughing at you or with you you have to
ask them I'm asking you have to ask them
I own I didn't I didn't ask him that
afterwards all I know what everybody
came over to me and said what a great
job I did okay so surely I guess it's
your job to follow up on the favor
accordingly what I know I don't have to
ask him anymore I'll do my own thing
thank you do me a favor can you drive me
around town no absolutely not just
follow up with me when I know right
where I want your friend Eric it also
would have been nice to kind of give me
a direction of what you're looking for a
direction when we said had I followed up
with you said we had we sat down to do
it I would give you a lot of direction
but your whole point is invalid because
you don't trust me so what information
would you have given me what I felt like
giving you would've been like Mad Libs
just filling a blank
bummed I don't have this under my even
tell you their names I'm not gonna tell
you what they do the bride is a blank
and she likes and when they met it was
blank and their favorite sex position is
blank by the way Ronny won't be here
next Wednesday's hosting a bat mitzvahs
friends doing next way and in three
weeks I'm gonna be performing a bris on
a kid what a great time didn't give a
[ __ ] that we had a live show [ __ ] I
guess he is back at work now go [ __ ]
yourselves okay